ฮะ
โอเค
สวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนดีนัก
เรียนทุกคนครับประวัตินี่คุณนี้
วินิจฉัยสกรีนหรือครู a  Share  screen
คู่นี้ตัวเล็กเดี๋ยวคนเล็กชายอะไรค่ะครู
เอกสบายดีไหมครับสบายดีค่ะคุณนี้สบายดี
ไหมคะเกือบนะกล้วยปอกสบายดีแต่เสียง
เหมือนไม่สบาย
เป็นอะไรครับคนไทยต้องพูดสบายดี
ก่อนกูไปก่อนว่าสบายดี
สบายดีสบายไหมสบายสบายสบายดีค่ะ
เอ๊ะ
ไม่เป็นไรไกลกันขนาดนี้
ผมขอ
แรง
เขาไม่มันมีฝุ่นมีฝนนะครับ
คอมพิวเตอร์มีฝุ่นออกมาเนาะกูเอกเช็ดทุก
วันเออ
แต่ก็ยังมีฝุ่นก็เลยเวลามีฝนจะ
ๆ
ยังโอเคค่ะเอทีเคเช็คแล้วค่ะ 1 ขีด 1 ขีด
โอเคโอเค
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
บอกว่าสบายดีแต่คือเวลามีฝุ่นหรือว่ากู
เองกินอะไรที่ไม่โอเคน่ะมันจะ
น้องใหม่กลับมันแพ้ใช่ไหมครับแพ้ค่ะแพ้
คู๋เป็นเหมือนๆมีปัญหากับโปรตีน
โอเคโอเคต้องกินจะกินอะไรนะกินแอปเปิ้ล
กินแครอทกินผักอันนี้สบายดีกินเหมือนผาก
หรือที่มันมีไฟเบอร์เยอะๆใช่ไหมมีอะนั้น
จะสบายดีนะคะโอเคโอเคแต่ว่าถ้ากินอะไรที่
แบบเป็นหมูมะอ่ะนะเป็นไก่ไก่
Action นะ
คะเนี้ยมากๆ
ไปอายๆ
ค่อยๆแล้วก็โอ๊ยโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
ผิดเราก็ไม่ดี
กินบ่อยๆคือหมูเสร็จเสร็จแล้วครูเอกก็
โอ๊ยๆ
พูดถึงของกินเดี๋ยววันนี้คุณเอ็กซ์ก็มีคำ
ถามแต่
เรามาคุยก่อนว่าวันนี้วันอะไร
จะเห็นโลกคุยแล้วยังไม่ขาว
ยักษ์แล้วคุยแล้วแต่ยังไม่รู้วันเลย
วันนี้วันอะไรครับคุณนี่วันนี้วันพฤหัส
ครับวันพฤหัสบดีนะคะเขียนได้ไหมคนนี้
เขียนได้แต่มันอาจจะคุยเขียนให้ไหมคุย
ช่วยเขียนหน่อยก็ได้ครับโอเค
วันนี้โอเค
วันพฤหัสบดีครับได้ได้ครับได้
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่
26 ครับ
26 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมครับเดือนพฤษภาคม
ปี
พศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022
เมื่อ
ปีพตตไรคะมีพ.ศ
2556  5  9
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงที่เราเริ่มพูดฮ่าๆเห็ด
เวลาเวลาคุณนิดน่ะคนนี้ตอนนี้นะครับเวลา
8:00 น 25 นาทีน
เช้าใช่ไหมคะเอ้าขับเช้าเราจะเอายี่สิบ
ห้าหรือยี่สิบครับครูเอ๋ขอโทษค่ะ
ขอโทษขอโทษ
คุณอิ๊กพูด 25 คู๋คิดยี่สิบ
แปดโมง 25 นาทีนะคะแล้วที่ถ่ายครับตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วนิทาย 20:00 น 25 นนาทีอ่ะ
ฮะโอเคเวลาตรงกันแต่ไม่ตรงกัน
ตัวเลขเหมือนกันแต่ของคุณนิคตอนข้ามของ
ครูเอ๋ได้เดี๋ยวนะถ้าเห็นมะงงละห้าๆคู่
นี้ก็ตอนเช้า
สวัสดีตอนเช้าชายๆๆอันนี้พระอาทิตย์นะคะ
พระอาทิตย์ครูเอ๋เนี่ยตอนกลางคืนตอนกลาง
คืนจะนอนแล้วกำลังจะนอน
โอเคค่ะคุยลบนะคะลบก่อนลบก่อน
ลบแล้วลบๆลูกจ้าลบอ่ะนักคนนี้คิดถึงสองกู
เอง
โอเคเมื่อกี้เราคุยกันเรื่องกินใช่ไหมคะ
ให้เขาจริงอย่างโปรตีนที่คุณครูเอ๋บอกว่า
เนื้อหมู
จะโอ๋
ใช่กินเหล้าเหมือนไม่ดีชาติคือไม่ใช่
หมูกับไก่เท่านั้นตอนนี้มีหมู
ไก่กุ้ง
หอยก็คือโอเคคู่เอกก็กินโปรตีนไม่ได้เลย
หรอครับ
จริงๆนะถ้ากูเอกไม่กินน่ะแข็งแรงมากแท้กู
เอกกินอ่ะจะ
ไม่สบายขอ
จะไม่สบายแปลกๆคู่เอกกินนะคะเราจะต้องกิน
กินแล้วก็มียาแล้วก็กินนะฮะก็วันที่กินยา
แล้วก็เหนื่อยเพราะไม่กินยาก็จะ
ภาษาไทยแบบฝึก Fast นะฝากใต้เวลาเหมือน
กับเรารู้สึกไม่สบายกินอะไรแล้วแท้มันจะ
จมูกแต่มันเหมือนมันมีอะไรติดไว้เราก็มัน
ไม่สะดวกง่ายหายใจออกไหน
ไม่เป็นไรได้อีกนิดหน่อยก็จะ
หยุดกินเนื้อสัตว์
โอเคพูดหยุดกิน 1 ปี 1 ปีครับผม 1 ปีหน้า
ครูเอ๋จะไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์ 3 เดือนขอโอเค
ครับ
3 เดือนไม่กินนะสัตว์ตอนฝนตกก็ต้องกิน
ไม่กินแต่จริงๆนะบางครั้งครับเวลาคุณนึก
รู้สึกว่าคุณนิคกินเนื้อสัตว์เยอะแล้ว
อยากให้ตัวกูนิดเนี่ยสภาก็จะกินผัดเยอะๆ
ชายครับนายก็กูเอกก็เดือนนี้เดือนหน้าปี
หน้าก็เดือนนะเดือนหน้าอาจจะเริ่มหยุดกิน
เนื้อสัตว์แต่คุณนิคสมัยก่อนคู่่ก็ก็กิน
แล้วสัตว์นิดหน่อยแต่มีหนึ่งอย่างนิด
หนึ่งตัวจริงอร่อยมากนะฮ่าๆๆอร่อยไหม
เหนื่อยบ้านเอ๋นะพอพ่อเนี่ยพ่อกินพ่อเป็น
คนไทยคำแต่คุณแม่นะแม่เป็นไทยจีนแม่ไม่
กินอ๋อ
แต่พ่อแม่แม่ไม่กินเพราะแม่ก็ห้ามพ่อกิน
พ่อซื้อแล้วเอาเข้ามานี่แม่จะโกรธมากขอ
เนื้อเดี๋ยวคุณนิดขอคิดเพราะอะไรกินแล้ว
เนี่ยเหมือนกันกับที่บ้านคืนนี้แต่ไม่รู้
ว่าใช่ไหมเป็นเนื้อวัวหรือเปล่าครับ
ใช่เนื้อวัวและเนื้ออะไรอีกเนี่ยอะไรอีก
มันคล้ายๆมีสีดำเนื้อควายหรอครับให้อ่ะมี
มีวัวนี่แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
เขาแบบนี้วัวหรือแมวครับ
Abstract รู้จักไม่เช้าสิกันโซ่แหวนโต๊ะ
ค่ะ
อันนี้วัววัว
โอเควัววัววัวๆโอเค
เวียนโอเคต้องคิดใช่มั้ยฟังแล้วก็คิด
ต่อไปนะฮะต่อไปต่อไปเล็กดูก็หมื่น
คุณนิคอะไหล่
โอเคอ่ะดิ๊กันนี้ควายเพราะมีเขายาวเลย
สังเกตตัวจะเหมือนกันนะคะอ่ะ
เธอเก่งมากกูเองฮ่าๆๆ
ขอโทษนะคะ
จริงมึงเด็กกูเล็กมีวีดีโอไม่ใช่มีวีดีโอ
มีรูปภาพเป็นต้น
แล้วคุณนี้ให้กูอีกว่าทำไมเถอะคืนนี้อีก
อยากเห็นครูเอ๋วาดรูป
คุณค่า
กูเห็นลบแล้วค่ะนี่ไงเหมือนใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียนวัวน่ะเนี่ยวัวคนนี้ไม่มีเขาไม่มี
ใช่ไม่มี
ยังเด็กๆหรอคะยังเด็กๆแต่ว่าวัวอันนี้ก็
เป็นสีขาวแต่บัวบางที่มันเป็นสีขาวสีดำ
มายในท็อปเอ็นด์วัวอยู่ต่างประเทศหรือ
เปล่าใช่ใช่แล้วแต่แล้วแต่วัวมีมี 2  3
สีสีน้ำตาลก็มีเนาะใช่สีราคายิ่งโง่วัว
คุณนิพินธ์กินไหมคะ
จริงๆแล้วคุณนิดเนี่ยตอนเด็กๆคู่นิดไม่
กิน
แต่ว่าตอนนี้กินตอนนี้กินครับ
เฮ้ยไอ้เอ๋เอน
ไปเปลี่ยนได้เดี๋ยวคู่นี้จะบอกคุณนิครู้
ไหมครูเอ๋นะคุยนะคุณนิคิดว่ากูเอ๋นะชอบ
ชอบในหวยคุณนี้คิดว่าครูเอ๋ชอบฮ่าๆเพราะ
ครูเอกไม่ก็คุยบอกว่าเคยกินเมื่อก่อนแล้ว
อร่อยก็เลยคิดให้ใช่คือที่บ้านกูอีกนะพ่อ
พ่อกินพ่อกินแม่ไม่กินพี่สาวแม่ไปกินครู
เอกสวยมากกรุงเทพแล้วก็มีคนในกินเนื้อ
ย่าง
จะ
เอาโอ้อร่อยมากคู่เอกก็ได้กินแล้วอร่อย
เสร็จแล้วกูเอกก็ไม่ใช่ว่า
คุณเองกูเองไม่ให้คุณได้เขียนมั้ยไม่รู้
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้โอเคบวมอ๋อมันจะมันจะบวมแบบ
สวยตุ้ยนิดหน่อยให้
ครั้งนี้ครั้งนี้แหละครั้งนี้ครั้งนี้ตรง
นี้ค่ะหากข้างเนื้อแล้วก็มีที่หัวเลยมา
ก่อนจะบวมขึ้นมาแล้วก็เจ็บเจ็บแล้วก็
แตกก็มีเลือดเห้ย
กินกินเนื้อวัวโอ๊ยโอเค
แล้วก็ทุกครั้งที่กินก็จะบวมบวมบวมๆแปลก
แสดงว่าแผลเราขับแบบนั้นให้กูเอกก็ได้กิน
เนื้อสัตว์มากๆไม่ได้เนื้อวัวเนี่ยห้าม
เลยค่ะอ๋อ OK พ่อกูนิกินแล้วโอเคไหมโอเค
ครับอร่อย
ไม่แตกคุณนิคจะจะเล่าให้สางว่าเพราะอะไร
คือไม่กินเพราะอะไรที่ตอนเด็กๆเหนือคุณ
นิดไม่กินค่ะเพราะว่าของว่าอะไรคะที่บ้าน
คุณอี๊ดครับคือคุณพ่อพ่อของคุณเอ็กซ์แม่
เป็นคนไทยเชื้อสายจีน
หาค่ะ
r ไทยจีน
เขียนไม่ครบนักเรียนเขียนอะไร
ก็คนไทยเชื้อสายจีนเนอะแล้วคุณแม่เนี่ย
เป็นคนไทยขอเอาไม่เหมือนบ้าน a บ้านเอก
คุณพ่อใช้คุณแม่ไทยเชื่อสายจีนส่งคุณนี้
เป็นหลักกันกับครูเอไอเอสหากคุณแม่ไทยก็
เป็นหน้าคุณเอ็กจีนมากนะคะ
ไม่นะโต
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้คืนนี้ปลา toey ตอนตอนเอา
นิ้วเอานี้
กู a  Thai  75% นักเรียนเออ
ขอบคุณในระยะไปที่หน่อยเปอร์เซ็นต์แต่ถ้า
เนี่ยจีนมาก
โอเคเราสองคนน่ะใครจีน
ต้องบอกว่าเราไทยมากกว่าจีน
ชอบก็คิดว่าคุณนิคเนี่ยไทย 75%
ถ่าย
แล้วก็ 4 ตีน
ตีน 25% ได้เนาะๆครับได้จริงประมาณนี้ลืม
น้อยกว่าก็ได้เพราะคุณนี้ก็แต่ก็ไม่รู้
ผู้นี้เนี่ยไม่พูดภาษาจีนแต่ฝั่งคุณพ่อ
เนี่ยพูดจีนได้หมดเลยค่ะเหมือนคู๋กูอ่ะ
พูดภาษาจีนได้หนึ่งคำ
คำว่าอะไรครับ
กินเสียอยู่อีกเส้นนี้หัวใจฉันเอาตัวต่อๆ
ไป
ขอเงินเขาอ่านเปาหรอ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะ
คุณนิคุณนี้จะคุณนิคไม่รู้คุณนี้จะถ้าได้
ยินคุณนี้อาจจะอ้อคุ้นคุ้นๆจะ
จำไม่ได้ว่าคืออะไร
ช้าก็จะอาจจะได้ง่ายนิดหน่อยก็กูไอ้หน้า
เป็นจีนไทยจีนแต้จิ๋วครับเหมือนกันครับ
เหมือนกันโอเคแต่เดี๋ยวคุณนี้เดินนั่งจะ
บอกเอ๊ะตกลงครูพูดอะไรหมอกฤษณ์แล้วก็พูด
เสือชาติคือพูดเลือดเลือกเราขออันนี้ฮะ
อันเนี้ยเส้นเลือดเพื่อจะเนี่ยเราเนี่ย
เป็นไทยจีนตายใช่ครับเราเป็นใครจีนผสม
ซึ่งบ้านคุณนี้กลับบ้านครูบีสอนเหมือนกัน
คือห้ามกินเนื้อวัวใช่
ทุกคนกำลังสงสัยค่ะคุณเอ็กซ์ทำไมทำไมทำไม
ทำไมกินไม่ได้ทำไมกินสเต็กไม่ได้ทำไมกิน
ทำเบอเก้อไม่ได้ทำไมมีอะไรอีกทำไมกินอะไร
ที่มีเนื้อวัวไม่ได้สงสัยละไห้ทำไมคะเวลา
คุณครูนิคเด็กๆทำไมพ่อแม่ไม่ให้กินเนื้อ
วัวครับเพราะว่าที่บ้านคูนี้ครับมีที่
บ้านคุณนี้นับถือนับถือหรือจะ
คุณแม่กวนอิม
จะปวดโอเค
มีค่ะหวี
เมื่อค.นี้หรือเราเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะพระ
โพธิสัตว์
ใช่ครับอายครับชื่อกวนอิมแบบเป็นพระ
โพธิสัตว์นะคะถ่ายเราก็เรียงกว่าพระโพธิ
สัตว์กวนอิมหรือสั้นๆอะไรนะคะที่คุณเล็ก
บอกคุณนิดจะเรียกว่าเจ้าแม่กวนอิมรัก
เหมือนกันค่ะเจ้าแม่ก็จะเรียกง่ายกว่านะ
เฮ้ยชายก็อันนี้ครับที่บ้านคุณนี้ก็คือ
นับถือเจ้าแม่กวนอิมครับโพธิสัตว์กวนอิม
ก็หรือด้วย
ไม่เห็นใช่มันเล็กๆขอกอดก่อนนครพระเอก
อ๋ออ๋อเออใช่เออสวยครับสวย
เป็นอยู่กูเขียวให้ขาดเป็นหยกค่ะ
จากไต้หวันหรือจีนจำไม่ได้ครับ
ใช่ก็อันนี้แหละครับทำให้คนไทยเชื้อสาย
จีนเนี่ยถ้านับถือเจ้าแม่กวนอิมก็จะไม่
กินเนื้อวัว
ใช่แต่มันก็แล้วแต่กดนะแล้วแต่ครอบครัว
บางครอบครัวเคร่งมากบางคร่อมกว่าก็ 50  50
คุณนายขาจริงๆคู๋นะไม่ได้เคร่ง
เกมคือกูเองนะพ่อพ่อพ่อกินเนื้อวัวครูเอก
กะแอบกิน
แต่ครูเอ๋นะกินและกูไม่สบายกูเอกก็โอเค
แม่กูเองนับถือเจ้าแม่กวนอิมโมค.
ศ.มันไม่ดีนะ
ไม่เป็นไรเป็นไรเพราะว่าเราอ่ะเป็นเรา
เป็นเหมือนลูกครึ่งเราตัดเราเลือกได้
เด็กกินหรือไม่กินทานเรียนก่อนนะคะจริงๆ
กูเอกก็ชอบแต่กินไม่ได้ก็โอเคเจ้าแม่
กวนอิม
เช้า
แล้วคนที่นับถือเจ้าแม่กวนอิมกินเนื้อวัว
ไม่ได้หรอคะกินไม่ได้ครับกับเพราะอะไรคะ
เรื่องเล่าไหมคะมีครับก็มีเรื่องเล่า
พูดผิดเรื่องละ
ไม่พูดมีเรื่องเล่าไม่ใช่นะคะมีเรื่อง
เล่าอะไรบางทีเวลาทนไทยโน้ตพูดเร็วก็จะ
ชอปรถปลาหลักรอเรือลอยลิง
โอเคมีครับคุณนิดมีเรื่องเล่าครับเกี่ยว
กับใครคะเกี่ยวกับเจ้าแม่กวนอิมครับถ้า
นักเรียนอยากฟังแล้วโอเคได้ครับก็เดี๋ยว
นะขอบคุณนิพูดเนี่ยเกี่ยวกับเนื้อวัวอ่ะ
คุณนิดท้องร้อง
หิวหรอคะเดี๋ยว
ผู้ next ตอนนี้เรากำลังจะพูดถึงเจ้าแม่
กวนปวดอาร์มผิวแล้ว
โอเคโอเค Age  The  Device ด้วย 2 พรุ่ง
นี้
จะได้ไม่กินจะได้ไปกินนะโอเคก็เดี๋ยวคืน
นี้จะเจอคนนี้จะย่ออันนี้ก่อนรถขึ้นแม่น
ก็
ไอ้นัทมันเล็กมีอยู่ว่าอะไรครับเป็นตำนาน
ก็คือ
เจ้าแม่กวนอิมเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเขาเขา
เขาเป็นองค์หญิงเนาะเป็นพระธิดาข่าวนั้น
ไม่มีพ่อก่อนใช่ไหมคะได้ครับมีพ่อครับพ่อ
ก็เป็นฮ่องเต้กับ
ฮ่องเต้กับพระราชาเหมือนกันมั้ยเหมือนกัน
ครับแต่ก็คือห้องๆใหญ่กว่าใช่ไหมใหญ่กว่า
ไหมนิคอำนาจใหญ่ปั่น
ให้ใช่ครับก็เป็นของทันจีนเนาะแต่น่าจะมี
หน้ามีมากกว่าพระราชาชายที่ภาษาไทยอ่ะจะ
เรียกว่าพระราชานะคะนักเรียนแต่ว่าถ้า
เป็นพระราชาของจีนคนไทยไม่เรียกพระราชามี
คนไทยจะเรียกว่าฮ่องเต้
แล้วก็ได้ก็แต่งงานมั้ยคะเอ่อแต่งแต่งงาน
ครับแต่งงาน
แต่งงานแล้วผู้แต่งงานกับฮ่องเต้เรียกว่า
อะไรคะของเห่าเด็กคนที่กำลังคิดอยู่ว่า
อะไรห้องห้องห้องห้องห้องๆ
ไม่คุยกับกูเอดูซีรีส์บ่อยๆคนนี้ก็
ซีรีส์จีนโอเคฮองเฮาขับชายนี่ฮ่องเฮากับ
ฮ่องเต้
แต็กอรรถแต่งงานกันแล้วมีรูปมีลูกกี่คนคะ
มีลูก 2 คนมีลูกสาวด้วยเนาะใช่กับชายครับ
ลูกสาว 2 คนอาจจะคุยวัดใหม่แต่ว่ามัน
เป็นคุยจะวัดใหม่ทำไม
เดี๋ยวนั้นเป็นดูนะคะอ่ามีลูกสาว 2 คน
ครับ
มึงอยู่
ไหนแล้วอ่าโอเคมั้ยโอเคชายลูกสาว 2 คน
ครับ
ลูกสาว
คนไปดีนะคนที่ 2 คุณนิถ้าลูกสาวของ
ฮ่องเต้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะองค์หญิง
ไหมคะใช่ครับเราจะเรียกว่าองค์หญิงถ้าของ
ไทยเราก็จะเรียกว่าพระธิดา
อเรสเจ้าหญิงๆหรือเจ้าหญิงขับแต่ว่าเป็น
ท่านเป็นของจีนก็องค์หญิงใช่ครับใช่
ก็มีองค์หญิง 2 ลอตเตอรี่อยู่ที่ 1 องค์
หรือสองคนพระองค์ 2 องค์ 2 องค์ครับ
เป็ดเป็นเป็นในหลวงราชินีองค์หญิงก็ต้อง 2
องค์ถ่ายค่ะ 8 คูณนี้กับครูเอ๋นะครู 2 คน
ในองค์นะอันนี้อ่ะก็คงไม่ได้ค่ะ
ครับ
ใช่ก็มีองค์หญิง 2 องค์ครับแล้ว
ก็แม่กวนอิมเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนก็คือเป็นองค์
หญิงคนที่สุดที่สอง
ชายมิกรูเอวัส Dream เพราะว่าองค์หญิง
องค์ที่สองเนี่ยอ่ะจะเป็นองค์หญิงเอาใจดี
ใจดีเราก็มีเมตตาครับชอบช่วยคนอื่นแล้วก็
ชอบทำความดีกูถ้ากู a หิวข้าวองค์หญิงหิว
ข้าวขอข้าวเหอะเหอะเห็นก็บอกรอไปก่อนพูด
เล่นไปเพื่ออะไรดีใจดี
เขากี่หญิงไม่มีเสื้อหนาวขอเสื้อ
อ่าโอเคก็เอาเสื้อให้ครับโอเคค่ะได้ครับ
วันนี้ก็คือองค์หญิงองค์ที่สองครับจ่าย
องค์ที่ 2 ก็ศาสนาพุทธนะคะครับๆพระนะคะ
เราก็องค์ที่ 2 ครับองค์ที่ 2 เนี่ยไม่
ไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์เลย
[เพลง]
ไม่กินหมูหมูไม่กินไก่ไม่ไม่ครับใช่ครับ
ก็พอเขามีความเมตตาพอเขาคิดว่ากินเนื้อ
สัตว์เหมือนฆ่าสัตว์
เห้ยชายก็เลยไม่กินดีมากครับชาย
ถ้าอย่างนั้นพ่อกับแม่ฮ่องเต้กับของเฮาก็
ดีใจไม่มีคนแย่งเนื้อสัตว์หรอกครับ
เจอรักนะจะรักเขาว่าลูกสาวใจดีแต่ลูกสาว
เอ๊ะทำไมสวยนะไทยเพราะว่ามีคนใช่ไหมคะมี
คนน่ะมีคนมีคนน่ะรักองค์หญิงที่ 2 มากๆยก
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋ต้องขยับนิดหน่อยเพราะว่า
อันนี้มันจะไม่เห็นหน้าจอ ka นี่ๆคน
ประเทศไหมคะคุณนิคเจอขีดให้ 7 คนเนี้ยรัก
นะคะโล่งหญิงที่ 2 องค์หญิงชื่อเมลศาลพระ
องค์หญิงเมลศาสตร์ o  o องค์หญิงใจดีองค์
หญิง
ไหว้มากๆนะคะรักองค์หญิงที่ 2 ล็อคเกิด
อะไรขึ้นครับคนนี้เกิดอะไรขึ้นเพราะว่า
องค์หญิงคนที่ 1 เนี่ยเป็นคนใจร้ายเป็นคน
ใจไม่ดีใช่ไหมครับก็อิจฉาครับอิจฉาเราก็
ใช้แบบนี้เลยครับโน้ทใหม่สวยๆทุเรียนน่า
จะไปเป็นนางร้ายได้นะในละคร
เป็นนางดีไม่ได้ใช่ไหมค่ะ
กดเลยนั้นเองเออได้เลยโอเค
ก็เขาชอบแกล้งครับแกล้งองค์หญิงคนที่ 2
องค์ที่ ๒ พุทธทาสครับแล้วก็จะไปบอกอ่า
ฮ่องเต้อองเฮาบอกว่าองค์หญิงองค์ที่สอง
เนี่ยทำแบบนั้นทำแบบนี้ไม่ชอบต้องแกล้ง
เขาพ่อๆท่อๆเอาอีกแล้วเนี่ยทำแบบนี้อีก
แล้วต้องทำอะไรนะเพราะมันไม่มันไม่ดีมัน
ไม่หนูไม่ชอบใช่หน้าบ้าบอๆๆใช่ใช่เอาทุก
อย่างให้คนอื่นให้ทำไมเอาทุกอย่างให้คน
อื่นมีคนรับถ้าชอบไม่โอเคใช่คิดจะขึ้น
เป็นเป็นใหญ่ร้องไห้ใช่ครับค่ะพ่อเชื่อ
ไหมพ่อเนี่ยหูเบาไม่เบาครับผู้บ่าวไข่ผู้
บ่าวคือผู้บ่าวครับก็คือเวลาใครพูดหรือ
บอกอะไรก็เชื่อ
เราคนนี้คุณอีกคุณนิคผู้หญิงบอกว่าคุณ
เอ็กซ์ไม่หล่อ
โอเคคนนี้เชื่อไหมเพราะคุณนี้เรา
นะครับผู้หญิงเอ๋อยากเช็คคุณนี้ว่าหูเบา
ไหม
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
คะตัวนี้
กำลังใจว่าคนนี้ก็เป็นคนดีหรือคนไม่ถ้า
คุณเป็นคนดีดีแล้วค่ะให้เอ๋เป็นคนไม่ดีคน
เดียวโอเค
เอาใหม่เอาใหม่ถ้าคุณนิดเป็นคนไม่ดีเนาะ
แล้วเปล่าคุยลองพูดใหม่ครับคุณนิคุณนิค
ผู้หญิงบอกว่าคุณนิไม่หล่อ
ทำไมผู้หญิงพูดแบบนั้นเนี่ยไม่ได้เดี๋ยว
จะต้องขึ้นไม่ต้องไปเอาเรื่องแล้วแบบนี้
อันเนี้ย of คุณนิหูเบาเพราะว่าเป็นคนทอม
ไม่ดีเวลาคนพูดอะไรมาไม่ดีคุณนี้ก็เชื่อ
หมดเชื่อกู a นะโกหก
แต่คุณเชื่อเนี่ยรถเบาไงสั่งใช่อ๋องั้น
พ่อคลองเตแหละฮ่องเต้นะพ่อก็ฟังองค์หญิง
ที่ 1 ขับเปล่าก็โกรธสิ่งที่ของฉัน
เหนื่อยครับชายอ่ะว่าไงต่อค่ะคุณก็ชอบ
โกรธครับฮ่องเต้เนี่ยก็แกล้งครับแกล้งทุก
อย่างว่าองค์หญิงคนที่ 2 ทำอะไรดีหรือมี
เมตตาก็จะไปแกล้งไปขัดขวางให้ให้ถึงง่าย
ชายครับไม่ให้ไปวัดด้วยใช่ไหมใช่ครับไม่
ให้ไปวัดด้วยแล้วก็จะติดคุกด้วยใช่ไหมใช่
ครับใช่ครับ
จับติดคุก
แน่
นะช้าแล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นค่ะคุณนี้คือออก
เวลาของเรากำลังจะผ่านไปนะ
ไปแล้วก็เพราะว่าองค์หญิงองค์ที่สองเนี่ย
เขาอยากออกบวชครับอย่าออกขวดหยาบเหมือน
บำเพ็ญเพียรก็คือปฏิบัติธรรมการนั่งสมาธิ
สั้นสมาธิปฏิบัติธรรมครับปฏิบัติธรรมแต่
ก็เพราะฮ่องเต้ครับฮ่องเต้เนี่ยไม่ให้ทำ
ท่า
นั่งสงสารแต่จริงๆแล้วก็สุดท้ายก็องค์
หญิงองค์หญิงคนเล็กเนี่ยองค์หญิงองค์เล็ก
ก็ทำได้นะครับก็คือเป็นขวดได้แบบนี้ใช่
ไหมคะให้เขาออกไปผู้ชายแล้วก็ปฏิบัติธรรม
นานนานจนได้เป็นพระโพธิสัตว์ค่ะข่าวแล้ว
เกี่ยวกับวัวยังไงคุณอีกเนาะกับวัวยังไง
เนี่ยเพราะว่าฮ่องเต้ครับฮ่องเต้เนี่ย
เสียชีวิต
On  A ชีวิตแล้วไปเกิดใหม่เป็นวัวอ๋อก็
เป็นฮ่องเต้ที่ทำไม่ดีที่ใช่ครับไม่ดีไม่
ดีใช่ไหมทำไม่ดีกับพระโพธิสัตว์ชายใช่
ครับทำให้ดีคนจะเป็นไปบวชไม่ให้บวช
นักเรียนมีต่อ 1 กินเนื้อด้วยนะใช่โอ๋
งั้นเนี่ยก็เลยเวลาตายแล้วท้องเตปายครับ
แล้วก็ไปเกิดใหม่คุณนิกูเอาอันนี้ออกมา
ได้ไหมเอาลูกออกก่อนได้ได้ๆครับเดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวคนนี้จะย้ายรูปครัวมาด้วยได้ๆๆครับ
จะได้อยู่ในหน้าซอยเดียวกันข้าวก็
ฮ่องเต้ครับ
แล้วเกิดใหม่เป็นห่วงขอมาก่อนปวดชาตินี้
เป็นฮ่องเต้ชาติต่อไปเป็นวัวครับพี่ชาย
ครับงั้นก็หมายความว่าถ้าและวัวก็เหมือน
กินพ่อใช่ครับใช่ก็ทำให้ค่าโพธิสัตว์
กวนอิมเนี่ยครับไม่กินวัวแต่ก็จริงๆถ้า
ปวดปกติครับโพธิสัตว์กวนอิมก็ไม่กินอยู่
แล้วใช่ก็ไม่กินอยู่แล้วใช่ครับแต่เป็น
ความเชื่อของคนจีนหรือคนไอ้เชื้อสายจีน
เนี่ยก็ออดูเรื่องไหว้กวนอิมใช่ครับพอรู้
เรื่องว่าอ๋อเพราะวัวเนี่ยเป็นฮ่องเต้
เป็นพระเธอเป็นพระบิดาพ่อของเจ้าแม่
กวนอิมต่างเกิดใหม่ก็ทำให้คนที่มีเชื้อ
สายจีนค่ะหรือเจ้าแม่กวนอิมและไม่กิน
เนื้อวัวค่ะก็บอกว่าใช่กินแล้วก็จะไม่
สบายด้วยนะ
ชอบลูกเอกก็ไม่กินนักเรียนแต่อร่อยมี
แต่ของคุณนิคน่ะที่บอกว่าไม่กินตอนเด็กมา
กินตอนโตเนี่ยเพราะว่า
บ้านครูนิดเนี่ยคือ
ตอนคุณนิคเรียนจบแล้วไปต่างประเทศครั้ง
แรกตอนอายุประมาณ 18 ค่ะครับแล้วพ่อแม่
ครูนิดเนี่ยสงสารพ่อแม่คุณนิคิดว่าต่าง
ประเทศเขากินเนื้อวัวเยอะเขาไม่กินแล้ว
หมูใช่แล้วหมูนิดหน่อยถ้าคุณนิดไปต่าง
ประเทศอ่ะเรากินเนื้อวัวไม่ได้เนี่ยกูนี่
กะจะอดข้าว
ประเทศอะไรคะนั่นน่ะอเมริกาและญี่ปุ่น
อเมริกาครับ
อเมริกาอ๋อที่บางคนนี้ก็เลยโอเคก็คือนิด
ไปต่างประเทศไม่ได้อยู่ที่ไทยไม่ได้อยู่
ที่บ้านที่ไทยกินวัวได้ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวจะ
หิว
หอมแต่ว่าทางอยู่ที่ประเทศไทยห้ามกินอยู่
ที่ประเทศไทยก็กินไทยครับ
แต่เอาเข้าบ้านได้ไหมเอาเข้าบ้านไม่ได้
อ๋อกินข้างนอกบ้านโอเคแต่ที่ก้านถ้ามี
เนื้อวัวยบ้านครูเอ๋นะคะโอเคมันบ้านกูอีก
ถ้ามีเนื้อวัวเข้าไปแม่จะเหม็นจังเลยอะไร
เนี่ยไม่ดี
ครับที่บ้านคุณเอ็กซ์แม่พ่อคุณเองก็เป็น
เหมือนกันค่ะเพราะว่าเขาไม่กินนะคะ
โอเควันนี้นักเรียนก็ทราบแล้วนะคะว่าคน
ไทยเชื่อใส่ Chic เสื้อใช้ยวันนี้ลิ้นพัน
นะเนี่ย in ดีนนะครับคนไทยเชื้อสายจีนอ่ะ
บ้าๆคนนะคะไม่ใช่ทุกคนบางคนที่ไหว้
เจ้าแม่กวนอิมครับจะไม่กินเนื้อวัวราคา
ใช่ครับอ่ะหมดเวลาแล้วคุณนิครับเลยเวลา
แล้ว
โอเคได้ก็ไว้รอดูว่าครั้งต่อไปนะเราจะมา
เล่าเรื่องอะไรให้สั่งได้ค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้
คุณนี้กับคุยไปก่อนนะคะอร่อยแล้วโอเคครับ
ไว้เจอกันใหม่ครับสวัสดีครับคุณเอ๋ค่ะ
สวัสดีทุกคนครับไปๆๆ